this show is brought to you by tracker
never lose anything again with tracker
go to the tracker.com that's the
tracker.com
and save 30 off of your entire order
that's right your entire order you save
30 when you go to tracker.com and use
promo code church that's tracker.com
promo code Church
and the show is brought to you by
anna.com go to onnit.com and use code
word search to save 10 on all of their
great optimization products like Alpha
Brain new mood stream tech immune and
shroom tech support
[Music]
oh [__]
[__] smooth tonight
[Music]
it's a bad [__] Champ
[Applause]
we'll keep Bridges get your [__]
blunt going
[Music]
church or what's happening now
April 27th
oh [__]
2016. I hope
[Music]
Jesus [__] Christ
get some shelter
this is too [__] much
strap a plan [__] we're coming
at you big tonight
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here with my main man Lisa
yet hey my main Kyra sultanovich what
are you [__] nuts or what is it Kira
or Kyrie it is Kira but I told you I let
you and one other person get away and
she's Dominican so I let the Cuban and
the Dominican get away with Kyra I used
to know a Spanish girl
his name was Kira and she was [__]
Dynamite her and her family were really
Dynamite when I first got into Comic the
parents have like a Mexican restaurant
on top of the Boulder and Boulder on the
U District
I never know what happened to those
people I had a couple sisters couple
brothers so she was Akira or a Kyra Kira
she was Akira she had a great sense of
humor
and she'd always you know make the tacos
and I giggle while I was there whatever
[__] my wife worked upstairs so there
was no drama there was no pressure we
could just be ourselves we should just
giggle all the time a dad would get
involved in the conversations and argue
and I would just go in there to light
her up yeah I would go in there so she'd
ask me to leave
because we get into it about music I
don't forget who she liked I just
[__] hate it like Springsteen or
something I'd go in there with facts and
just blow her [__] mind but I see you
liking a lot of music and that's not in
a bad way no I do like I feel like you
have a pretty uh wide
array palette of music now did you hate
that music because she liked it was it
like something that you just hated
because she liked it or no I don't
remember what the argument was about but
when it comes to music I will go home
and plot your [__] demise you
understand I think I listen to terrible
music
I don't care about terrible music it's
somebody
sticks up to me like Steps up like a
couple weeks ago I was in a meeting with
some people and this woman said
something about Adele
and I had to lay into it because of what
happened at the Academy
whatever happened you know what happened
as I'm watching this I see this [__]
chick it's horrible and the voice is
horrible and everything is horrible and
I don't make you know I know music I've
been through enough concerts to know
that there's no concert that's 100 the
walls everything has even as a comic
sometimes you go into a theater and and
you go watch a comic in the field and
you're like this is [__] terrible
that's why I don't like theaters because
it's such a big [__] Gap yeah you
know there's nothing like going to see
any type of show and the sound is not
right you get irritated it's not about
the 22 dollars or the 35 it's about
I can't even listen to this I'm getting
a [__] headache it's amazing how much
that matters like I went to see a show
and the lights were on took me
completely out of it it's a great
comedian who I love but the lights are
on the whole show for some in the
audience yeah
it's like sex
look it's okay to have a little bit of
light but it's nice when it's dark you
know but put you in the mood
I I did
um a Show recently where I had three
Comics ahead of me and I had to tell the
guy that put the show together I go I'm
begging you please can you play so Owen
uh Owen Smith Owen Smith was on stage I
go please I'm begging you can you turn
the lights down in the audience well
Owen's on I go he will not mind he will
actually thank whoever is doing this
trust me just trust me and I had to beg
this guy and he finally turned the
lights down in the audience and Owen was
like thank you so much for making this
into a real Comedy Room now instead of
you know like a corporate you know
luncheon
it makes a huge difference when you were
a child were you a funny child did you
step out in class and crack jokes yeah
yeah I mean that was you you all solely
I I did I didn't I like to be
like a little bit but not like comedians
I had like a little joke that I would
say quietly so a couple people could
hear but I was always I was always like
a class clown that was more me like not
more not jokes like I wasn't a Class
Clown but I would get irritated
I would get irritated in the same way I
would get irritated now
and I would get irritated on the bus and
I would go off on the bus not only as a
kid about what eight minutes into it I
go off on a bus and that's what people
laugh
and then you go off in front of your
hangout your Deli so we had a deli and
we had it on the front of the deli and
I'll be honest with you like if there
was a circle of six three these guys
could have been top-notch comedians yeah
hysterical and you had to pick things
and what you said better be [__] good
because you only get one shot at this
yeah and if you get the Limelight and
you get them rolling you got the stage
however long you get them rolling that's
Street comedy it's kind of weird you
know I really envy people who grew up
like that my friends that I grew up with
that I'm still best friends now you know
were in each other's weddings you know I
mean we we vacation together you know
we're all best friends still
um none of them ever wanted to be funny
or be a comic or even I mean honestly
even public speaking probably scared the
hell out I grew up with such an
interesting group of girls I'm the only
one in that group I don't know maybe
that's I attracted like I attracted them
to me because maybe I didn't want the
competition I don't know but a lot of
comments balance listen
I have my comedian friends yeah but if I
have my choice
right now in my life I go to jiu jitsu
at 12 o'clock and then my balance
because nobody talks to me about comedy
I'm just a fat white belt
a Fat Sweaty white belt he smells like
hamburgers and [__] Reef of this kid
you know so it balances it out I don't
want to hang out with comedians all day
and be doing for your life at one part
of your career from the three to eight
year mark yeah you need them live in an
apartment with four comedians yeah you
need to be around comedians because
that's how you dive yourself in there
that's how you there's a word you sink
yourself into them immerse yourself
immerse yourself into a lifestyle but
then you grow as a human being and you
get an apartment you find the wife is
significant other my point was this that
it's funny this is why I like it dark
that's the Lord
and it's really weird you ever see the
movie what's the movie when uh
Al Pacino when he's a football coach Any
Given Sunday you will see that yeah yeah
yeah a long time ago interesting line in
there
and I used to host at the store that's
how I used to see her young cure at the
store yeah Kyra Kira doing her thing a
really pretty carer but very unassuming
very quiet you weren't [__] you didn't
say much you only spoke if you were
spoken to you know I used to watch you
I'm a big Watcher I mean I talk to you
but I'm watching
all right that's just my nature I mean I
talk to you I may not [__] even like
you
but I'm watching you may be the [__]
ugliest girl in the room and there's a
hot girl but I'm watching you because
you're interesting to me that there's a
hot chick over there with one Momo and
you're a fat chick with [__] heels on
there's six guys chasing around you you
following me yeah so you're doing
something right that [__] chick over
there that thinks she's hot she's got
good [__] she's doing it wrong you
follow I've always liked people like
when I first got to the store I used to
watch dice yeah
okay a little secret about nice
you know what diet you know what dies
drives dice crazy what we don't talk
so he'd be by the stairs go ahead close
your eyes 1998
oh yeah yeah
I'd stand by the Sun
there could be 80 [__] people over
there
I would stand by the Sun
after an hour you absolutely have to get
up and walk over and go what's up
because you got these 80 people yeah why
don't you have that one
you know what I'm saying it's the same
thing with a girl I'm an ugly dude but I
pulled some tail in my life not cause
I'm good looking because it's psychology
she comes in everybody's life a
cigarette when she walks by me I Spit on
the [__] floor she's gonna turn her
back and go what's going on everybody
loves my [__] titties but you haven't
said a word about them yeah I don't give
a [__] about you
she's gonna go get a drink get a
cigarette and come to war and sell me
her [__] even though she don't want to
give it to me you follow me and the more
I walk back she's gonna go everybody in
this place wants my [__] but this fat
[__] he's got the answer
he's got the answer to my problems it's
so weird how psychology works yeah in
Any Given Sunday he's losing the black
quarterback Jamie Foxx right and he
takes him aside he goes listen this
ain't no big deal
he goes you're in front of 80 000 people
today but this ain't no big deal I want
you to think about being at home
One play left your mom just caught you
got to go home for dinner you got one
point
what's the guy say run to the Cadillac
and hook a [__] left
when I heard that I remember going to
the store and appreciating the storm
because I don't have to see these people
for me to go on a roll
I gotta go back to 88th Street Park
I gotta go back to 82nd Street Park I
can't stand straight I gotta stand
sideways right I know these things once
I stand sideways and start talking this
way
my head's that way but I'm standing
sideways I'm on 88th Street Park I'm on
82nd Street on the corner I would always
look that way because cars are coming
this way I don't want no car to hit a
car and hit me you know what I'm saying
you got to pay attention you might be
cracking jokes so it really made sense
to me that's why I don't like the lights
on because I don't have to [__] see
these people I don't have to see them
[__] judge me yeah the wall you know
what the Wall's about the Wall's about
he made a statement when not after a
show I wish I could do a [__] show
with a warn between me and the fans
are you serious yeah he said he said
that's how it all started
okay I didn't know that
now what do people do you think people
respond to that though
well if you it was disgusted a couple
weeks ago the concert the wall the
actual 80 the 1980 concert
was but they performed all four sides of
the album yeah but while they're
performing midgets dressed as [__]
whatever the [__] they are are building
a wall around them yeah until finally a
walls in front of them
and then for Comfortably Numb Dave
Gilmore plays the solo on top of the
wall and then the Wall comes down and
there's a couple songs after the wall
comes down and that's the [__] story
it's interesting to me that you
you were uh finally like you tried to be
funny but then you're also like watching
because I I associate watching with
being an introvert yes which I don't on
the outside you don't seem like it but
you're both like I'm I'm 100 like 99
listen for 33 years
I would be embarrassed to make this
statement then I watched the biography
on Marlon Brando yeah
and for years all modeling Brandon would
do is go downstairs go downtown and sit
in a phone booth
and sit and watch people
I love it I love sitting there watching
what makes people think
well can I I want to say something and
it's going to come across creepy but
it's not meant to be creepy
um I like to go to Korean baths it is
very well known that I really really
enjoy
Korean bats it's all women obviously
there's a separate men's section but
we're all naked and uh I like to watch
women in not a sexual way at all
um there's a vulnerability when you are
ever been to the Korean baths do you
know what they're all about okay so
there are places where you sit they they
bathe differently right they Crouch down
on like little stools and instead of
like they have stand-up showers as well
but they also sit with like a sit-down
shower it's really kind of crazy and
bizarre but also awesome and when
they're bathing and I'm talking about
strictly Koreans and is it like a nice
area is it like a gym locker they're
Korean Spas everywhere no no it's not
it's not a gym locker room at all it's
completely different it's a whole
different experience but it's kind of
religious and they have rituals and they
scrub their bodies and they clean their
bodies in a certain way
I was brought up in saunas and steam
rooms and I don't [__] with jacuzzis
because I just feel like there's some
[__] tuberculosis happening that's a
good no no no I did not [__] with any
kind of water any kind of liquids ever
um unless it's bubbling up from the
ground then that's the springs in
Colorado yes 100 I'm all over that but
um I steam I sauna I go into like they
have all these different rooms like
there's a a charcoal room and a jade
room and Clay room and you know all the
different I love that [__] but
specifically when the women are washing
themselves again not sexual at all
I like to watch and observe the ritual
of it now that they when let's say a guy
goes into a Korean [__] bath house
yeah he goes into the guy section off
the guy section and uh who bathes him
two women or two men oh they bathe you
yeah they bathe you yeah
top three layers of your skin awfully
you see your skin on the floor yeah like
a snake Oh I thought it was like a bunch
of people showering like bathing
together
that's that's part of it they scrub the
hell out of you it's a mugging with soap
oh God yeah that's what it is so is it
painful
I like it but I like a little bit of
paint
a little bit I don't I hate the good
times oh God but it feels so good it's
cleansing your skin is your largest
organ sorry guys sorry but your skin is
your largest organ on your body so it's
like somebody massaging your kidneys or
your pancreas I mean they're they're
they're cleaning your
your soul yeah but you describe it like
a mugging that sounds like it's like a
general rubbing very aggressive so I
have taken my husband to these because
if you're gonna be married to me you
have to be open to going and he said
once that the do this little Korean man
is just wearing like little black Korean
underwear lifted up his testicles and
just went and just gave him a nice
little scrub on the taint and put them
back down and then just like smacked him
on the head and was like get out of here
hard to beat and just thinking about it
you know it's the best I don't even know
how you respond Joe how would you
respond if you were if someone convinced
you to do that I went on testosterone in
2013.
good friends
and I was never horny in my life
and my wife is pregnant
and never hornier yeah never
okay
yeah I mean it was horrible and I would
drive over to that massage parlor on a
Lancashire and I would sit out there
and the thought of somebody massaging my
back
would give me such anxiety that I would
just take off and go home and jerk off
seriously oh you have no idea you have
no idea the only people behind me well I
don't even like people standing [__]
behind me and I've said this before if I
was a woman I'd be a good piece of ass
but you would never doggy style me I'm
not ever giving up my eyesight on you
yeah just a thought of somebody's
scrubbing me out it's just so impersonal
like I don't even like my wife besides
me you know what I go to that place over
here with her
and we both sit together and they rub
your feet yeah on your shoulders they
have a happy hour for 25 bucks yeah yeah
I've done those yeah I like that stuff
I'm a big now why did why did you grow
up in saunas and steams Russians Soviets
are all about saunas and steam rooms
they beat you with uh yes I saw leaves
like like eucalyptus leaves they called
vanity they make them into like a little
broom
that's what a video is it's a broom so
they make these special leaves usually
eucalyptus because of the essential oils
that are inside the leaves and they beat
you they beat you you side your face and
it's amazing
it's amazing I cannot tell you how much
I love a good just [__] up like get
the heel of your foot
like in my ass oh I love it I love it I
love it I love it when you live oh you
live up here and when I used to live in
Hollywood yeah
the Hollywood y opens at five and at
505. it's packed with Russians yeah the
Russians I'm sorry I want to just
apologize no no no and they the first
cup listen
the first couple times they'd have the
hoods on like the cake you have to wear
it yeah they're like rushing KKK I go in
there and it'd be four [__] Russians
with a hood and one black guy sitting
there like nothing happened and I'd sit
next to them like embarrassing who's
gonna throw the first bunches they
really were hoods yeah they were okay
let me tell you yeah they're like wizard
hats and [__] and here you are 505 Stone
to the gills I'd walk in there I'd wake
up take a shower eat something and I'd
smoke dope in those days I used to get
up at 4 15.
I just quit Coke I needed something
quick yeah because I was losing my mind
at some point yeah so I would wake up at
four jump in the shower and I'd be at
the Y and I'd get stoned and I'd eat
like a little breakfast and I'd shoot
over to the [__] wine
and they'd be in there and they'd drink
shots of vodka yeah and after about two
weeks they offered they were very close
in that Society yeah they offered and
this was something I did for about a
year and a half and
I knew their names and I
I know what they did but I really didn't
they were doing this shots in this honor
sure yeah yeah yeah and I didn't really
care none of my business
the only problem you know who gave me a
hard time the Russian women in the pool
in the the heated pool yeah the heavier
Russian women and only guys in there
they would battle me they cut they don't
do they do their like little yeah with
their head above yeah
right yeah they hang out to the wall and
they just kick for 20 minutes yeah yeah
yeah and you're like this ain't doing
nothing for you very interesting
well I grew up my mom was uh she was
hell-bent on teaching me how to it's
called paritsa
I was eight years old and she goes all
right I'm teaching you this is how you
do it she would teach me how to steam
how to sauna the correct ways you sit
down afterwards you wrap yourself up
here's what your body's doing your body
is now now it needs to cool down to help
your circulation they would put stuff
so you first all right so you get to
know why you jump in the shower I
wouldn't swim first I'd go in here first
because in the back of my mind I wanted
all the coke to get out of my system
so I would jump in there first I would
drink a bunch of water and I'd go into
the
not where the steam comes out of the
wall right that's where the rocks are
sure that's awesome you're going there
first for 20. yeah it's great 20 minutes
is perfect go right from then I'd shower
and shoot right back into that Steam
and they'd already be in the steam
before me and they'd be in there
drinking they'd have water and vodka and
then they put some [__] Russian
malukia juice on the steamer it was like
eucalyptus mixed with just oils and the
guy would talk to me all the time this
is for your health yeah these for your
eyeballs you you see people who are
giving you evil you know I was loving it
I was you know I knew the names they
were very nice it was one black guy that
was a uh he had a security system a
security business yeah so he worked all
night and he'd go in there at five
and you could smell
[__] alcohol veins he was a boozer
so he'd go and he was very smart yeah if
you're going to be an alcoholic at least
get that [__] out of this yeah yeah it's
detox that's why they drink inside the
sauna he would get in there and taking
it back in the system he would walk in
that Hammond sweat it out and then the
Russians would walk out he's laying on
his back and he'd take a little nap in
there
and then he'd do what he was doing but
what I was doing without the swim I'd do
all that and like jump in the pool my
wife wouldn't get up till eight I had
three hours to kill yeah I would jump in
the pool for 45 minutes of lapse in the
heater pool no way
through the whole [__] thing
I do 20 of kicking and then I put the
thing between my legs and then I just
pull non-stop for 20 minutes and then I
would just [__] do it all together
yeah I was doing that in the morning and
then at night I was going back and
hitting the bag
and then hitting it with my hitting the
bag and riding the bicycle that was it
wow just doing Weight Watchers all this
[__] these people we have to do chiro
and micronutrients listen
Weight Watchers don't give a [__] if you
eat fruit all day then you know what I'm
saying they don't give a [__] it's only
you ain't diabetic they don't give a
[__] yeah but it's so weird I grew up I
came from Cuba I grew up
and in my generation I don't know what
it's called I was in the millennial I
wasn't a pre-millennial
Society American society
made you not hate the Russians but made
you in the late 60s and 70s yeah I think
hate the right words with Fidel which
I'm Cuban so I I didn't feel hate but it
made you be aware of Russians like it
just made you like look out for Russians
like to America it was Boris and Natasha
oh yes it was that it was Buddhist
Natasha well Russian people have always
had this uh vague mystery about them
because of the USSR and and you could
make fun of them because guess what it's
like the Amish they weren't going to
ever find out they weren't allowed
television my dad taught told me that
when he was like in probably you know
late 60s
um
he uh he was probably if he was born 47.
you know he's like probably just out of
college
they got a bootleg version of The
Beatles
whatever album came out in the late 60s
I forget which one that was
right let it be yeah it could probably
let it be probably let it be he they got
a bootleg and it was the biggest coup of
anyone's life and they
they had to secretly tell people because
it was at a time when neighbors would
rat out each other you know what I mean
and they listened to this
uh Beatles album
in like a dark dungeon somewhere like
underground in someone's basement
I'm sure there was a look of course in
Cuba and Cuba yeah and they were so uh
unaware of anything else that was
happening in the world because of
propaganda and so Russians were this
vague mystery and you could you could
make up what whenever anything is
mysterious people just start making up
their own you know stories about what it
is because nobody knows you know
obviously I wasn't alive then but to me
from what I've seen and read in history
books it seems like like the Russians
during the Cold War were like today is
like the like Isis or something like
like to that level of fear fear in the
United States because I remember going
law I'm scared of writing a missiles
didn't they do like yeah didn't they do
like bombs bomb drills in the in the
schools
oh because of Russia I thought it was
like the Cold War I could be totally
wrong yes but I don't think it was Isis
style because
putting out YouTube videos of beheadings
oh boy yeah it was just uh it was a
different fear they had remembered when
I first came from Cuba every building
had a shelter
you can walk into a building in the
United States
that at somewhere in the first floor it
said bomb shelter my high school was
built originally to be a bomb shelter
there you go it was built into the side
of a mountain into the side of a hill
and it had no windows
my high school had no windows shout out
to any mcateer alumni in San Francisco
it was built originally and the guy who
built it built insane asylums
quick he was the guy that was like
here's what you do you make everything
inside a maze so they can never find
their way out and that was my high
school
it was insane and it was a bomb shelter
and then they were like this fear of
bombs is a little crazy let's just make
it into a school and that's how we ended
up going there my first experience with
Russians were in 85 in San Francisco
yeah we were there that was my first
was it a good experience
one of the Cuban refugees I ran
went well credit cards or something and
then I got to meet them look who's I'll
never forget that's what we call I
didn't know their names
are you first in Russian are you first
generation girl no I was born I was born
in the Soviet Union oh you were yeah
because like I'm I think I'm like third
or maybe even fourth generation Uh
Russian and uh something else right
right next to that yes and I don't so I
don't have any
like Russian Pride like I don't have any
culture from that yeah like even like
when I see like when I see it in movies
it never bothers me like I don't know
it's not like right right no it's it's
definitely different now where do
Russian Jews come from Russia or Israel
the Israeli Jews that moved to Russia
other way around usually well they they
were scattered so Russians were
scattered I'm sorry uh Jews were
scattered everywhere so you got Jews in
Mexico City
you got Jews in Spain you got Jews that
went to Russia Cuba you got Jews that
went to uh Israel Canada has a big but
even before the Canadian immigration
before the States and Canada
so I'm talking like you know 100 years
ago let's say
Russians um I keep saying Russians Jews
went to
maybe five or six different places one
of them was the Soviet Union the Soviet
Union said we'll take you in
uh but here's here are the rules uh
everybody wears Gray
and we all get paid the same you'll have
a place to live and you'll have some
food we can't guarantee
what you'll have but just get in line
and wait and you'll eat and they'll be
closed but again they're all going to
look the same and it was like Star Trek
in the sense of like everyone's outfits
are just gonna be the same
no different shape you know just get
used to it
um and so a lot of Jews went there when
they got displaced well but then like
like the Stalin and then look in World
War II that's what that's when I was
saying they left like they were like the
same sort of not to the level of Hitler
but like they were killing and getting
and rounding up the Jews and stuff like
not letting them shoes are always
getting rounded up I mean look we're in
North Hollywood I'm sure there's some
Jews getting around it up right as we
speak right now I mean there's no joke
it's always happening it's like just
like you're bored one night it's like
let's go round up some juice
[__] up
it is that's why I think you know Jewish
people and black people should get along
better and how long we came from Russia
Russia two okay so you don't remember
the dick like me no no but I have been
back
and there's a feeling of like when I go
I see people my age and I look at them
and I go maybe that would have been a
friend of mine maybe I'd be working in
that building with them like I wonder
what my life would have been like I do
not think I would have been a stand-up
comic there's no way first of all it
didn't exist
it didn't exist no no even yaakov
Smirnoff talks about how what he did
wasn't comedy
he he kind of made up what he thought
was stand-up comedy but really he was
like a an emcee for Live Events and a
host for live events in Russia yeah
because it didn't exist there was no
such thing
it was just
I mean even still to this day they have
quote comedy clubs and it's really like
like what the Groundlings is here
you know they do like sketches
comedy is very new to so to Russians
sorry not Soviet not Soviets anymore
it's very new very new and by the way
San Francisco I probably will not go
back to perform there in a while why I
did a show a couple years ago
um whenever I advertise I'm going to be
in San Francisco the entire Russian
Community comes out which you would
think would be a good thing and yes it
is the support is fantastic but I went
specifically to record a CD I wanted to
put out a CD this was like three years
ago right when CDs were still relevant
uh they're not anymore by the way if
anyone's wondering
um and I go up there I set up the
microphones I get equipment my husband
helps me we get a a venue I do the whole
thing I get an opener a feature Act
make sure everything's right the lights
everything right these [__] Russians
sitting right next to the mics I mic the
audience right so you can get the laughs
are talking the entire time or heckling
me in Russian not in a bad way they
think they're helping are yelling out
suggestions talking about how we took
piano together do you remember in
Russian yelling [__] out in Russian
they're getting drunk
[__] the Russians never again I can't
perform in San Francisco I think you
should absolutely put that out I would
totally for 99 cents I would totally
well that's why I said to you I can't go
the closer I go to my hometown right
yeah it's not gonna work it's not gonna
work how do I know it's not gonna work I
did one eight years ago and while I'm up
to the day yelling tell them about when
you rob this guy's house
really or the ones that are sitting in
front because they're they're still
stuck in the you know USSR and they have
their arms crossed and they don't want
to [__] laugh because for 30 years
they had to wait in line for salami and
they had to wear shoes that were three
sizes too small because [__]
communist that's when people are like so
and so is a socialist or someone this
politician is really a communist [__]
you you don't even know what communism
is it's wearing shoes that are three
sizes too small all right that's what
being a socialist is it's not [__] I
want to help uh this chick have an
abortion you socialist you know what I
mean why should my money go to her
abortion because then her kid won't grow
up and you know carjack you in 20 years
all right [__] so let her have an
abortion so you can keep your Mazda but
people think they know what socialist is
and what communist is they have no idea
they have no idea you you know what it
is I know what it is
you know I I heard you've heard I've
heard your family has told you well I
had the same situation with you my
cousins are musicians
and they came to Burbank to record they
drove by The Improv and saw my name went
in and told Rita who they were and Rita
called me and that's how I met my
cousins and I went down there they came
to the show then we went to Kansas yeah
and I've told the story before while
we're in Canada is we're talking awesome
they started harmonizing
Stairway to Heaven
and I can feel the Goosebumps I got also
not wanted to cry in front of them but I
couldn't
and they were telling me how they had an
album and they had to listen to it
or the lookout yeah that you know they
passed it they had to bury it yeah and
hide it you know and you sit there and
you think how lucky you are that you've
given away albums right and these people
would have taken any of these albums
any of these out they didn't care what
band just just one of them just to hear
music yeah and just the American way you
know
you're Russian you grew you were born
there but you were raised in a Russian I
say it all the time that
the transition is amazing and how what
like for me I had to eat hot dogs to
become an American when I was five I
felt that the more American food I ate
like my daughter my daughter's three and
there's always drama at dinner time
she likes spaghetti hot dogs and french
fries and ketchup she'll put ketchup on
[__] cereal if I let it you
understand me on chocolate milk
at those ages I was eating my mom and I
had a great relationship I was eating
whatever Cuban tongue yeah oh whatever
when I went to I got Americanized
and I would go home and she'd go black
beans and rice in the steak [__] you I
want SpaghettiOs you know because it
made me feel like I'm American that was
my comfort food
make me become people have no idea
people have no idea I tell people all
the time how lucky you are the
advantages you have I've never felt
racism I could sit here and tell you a
bunch of stories I'm very fortunate I
got into movies you know I didn't get
into Montreal but I got into movies
right you know so you take you pick your
[__] battles yeah and I've been very
fortunate you know but
I see how people
don't respect what it is to be an
American like like we fight hard you
don't know what it's like to go into a
grammar school in the 70s
and not speaking the language
and [__] faking the funk because as
soon as you open your mouth
you know they're gonna know you're not
like them
well uh I was a refugee
so all this like refugees and all this
what people think about refugees
nowadays and yes maybe they're different
if we were refugees until I was eight we
weren't citizens until I um I turned
either eight
probably eight eight or nine so my
parents would tell me
don't don't get in trouble okay
they're gonna they're gonna kick us out
of this country if you [__] around and
have us come down to the principal's
office
we're out
because they Associated I even tried to
do a bit about this I I used to a long
time ago but like they Associated public
school because I went to a public
elementary school
with the government which it is no with
the government
your fans know what that sound is no
they know they know pop
um I look I love how it comes in a pill
box too
I love that listen if you're gonna
[__] play the game
look I I wish you well with your
glaucoma
uh so if I got in trouble and the
principal wanted my parents to come down
to his office they were like you're
gonna get us kicked out of this country
we're out you understand we're not
citizens don't [__] around
so I had to
I had to watch myself then then I turned
eight and we're like all right [__] I'm
a [__] citizen now so I can do
whatever I want now like all of a sudden
I got like a big head I was walking
around like look at me like ripping up
my green car like I'm done you know I
was like all right here we go this is it
I'm American now that's that's the
moment that I felt
I was an American see I was told a
different story I was told that if I
didn't get good grades they kicked me
out
because they didn't need me
and I was told they're going to kick us
out of the country
oh my parents told me not they're gonna
they're gonna [__] in if you don't get
A's and B's if you get C you still
[__] uh
oh yeah yeah so I was like I don't want
to get the agency you look a little
white tonight oh good sure just 600. um
well kind of what I was saying earlier
were like where since I'm third
generation rush I don't feel like a
connection to Russia it's not that I
don't feel American but I grew up in
like East Coast like like right outside
of Boston
there's American Pride but it's not like
I was talking to someone today in
England
and when you see like a UFC and there's
like a foreign fighter their fans go
bananas
but when it's an american guy
occasionally like uh cowboy Cerrone or
or Roy Nelson but most American fighters
don't that's not like it's not like go
America so it's it's something weird
like it's it's kind of funny how two
immigrants are the most patriotic ones
all right it's interesting
I you know in my world
I don't know I I I'm proud to be a Cuban
but I'm also proud to be an American
yeah I'm proud that I ended up becoming
an American I paid taxes I'm uh I'm uh
why'd you laugh at that excuse me God
damn it that means I get to call myself
an American well you know what it's part
of trying to be a productive member of
society for [__] 35 40 years I was an
unproductive member of society
I was trying and for the first time at
the age of 50. I became a productive
member of society you know what I'm
saying so that's a part of America being
an American is
you know all those little things yeah I
got felonies so what that's part of
being an American having a second chance
[__]
you know all these things you can't
throw at me because that's the American
way
you were Russians uh refugees God knows
what your dad was about to go through or
your mom yeah you know and all of a
sudden you came here what's that called
a second [__] chance right right so
you can't judge me on any of those
things we all make [__] mistakes no
matter what the [__] you do you know
it's not like I was out there
falling out of trees giving out Cosby
pills I seducing [__] young women you
know what I'm saying
I wonder if there's an edible called
Cosby pills that's a great idea yeah
yeah it should be right it'd just be
Bells he would go nuts but you spell it
with a z or the k-o-z oh man and a
picture of a chick just passed out
it's edible so you just what did you
just have a little star I had a that was
my third start for this evening but what
so I know nothing I'm a complete no we
opened up with 600 milligrams four stars
oh okay so 400. no no no you know but
the milligram you know how long that'll
take you like what what kind of you know
I know zero no no no no no no you don't
know nothing I'm Square no no when you
eat one of these things yeah you don't
know nothing oh I see
[Music]
on Monday we did a podcast and he left
and I I was doing I was putting the
podcast up and I just woke up at 1 30 in
the morning
I was telling them a story and he was
like this
even worth telling you a [__] story
and I went home and on all the nights I
was pretty high too so I went home tried
to watch television and I was like I
can't deal with this and I [__] went
right to sleep and I got up the next
morning he's telling me a story how he
got up at 1 30 in the morning his
girlfriend kept paging him texting him
and
ask them where the [__] he was I love
that [__] when I fall asleep on the
couch
when I'm saying double I know I'm there
you know like sometimes you see double
on these
it crosses a little it's tremendous put
you in a safe environment so what do you
think it is I'm always curious about
this when people like myself for example
um when you explain that to me the whole
it's it's tremendous you see double
and you're having a great time to me I
get such major anxiety the way that you
get anxiety getting a massage or someone
standing behind you I hear you
so imagine that's how I feel like when
you tell me that I start to sweat like
oh my God that does not sound great to
me at all
and I've gotten high before I've never
had edible never had an edible don't get
me wrong
if I know I didn't have to go to a
massage today
I would have been in there getting my
pipe sucked but I just don't want to go
in there go listen no massaging just
sucky don't touch nothing [__] yeah
don't [__] I'm just an animal
like I have no concept of those things
like how nice it is to be massaged to
get a finger up your ass I'm always
thinking about the negative when I'm
looking down
so [__] that [__] sorry to bring it up
I'm just thinking about it you know my
paranoid is kicking another you talked
about anxiety
these things get you anxiety too I
like I feel like it'd have a negative
effect on me
I feel like it's like it brings out
whatever maybe you don't want to come
out the only anxiety I get on these is
when I get shortness of breath because I
do something too quick
and the shortness of breath shoots right
to my mind and also the cortisol shoots
out and I break out into a sweat in my
body but then I get it together I just
breathe through my nose and not my mouth
and
it all evenses out I put I put something
in my stomach too sometimes when you
start getting the anxiety from The Reef
you eat a little something oh okay okay
it kind of love bread with butter yeah
you know either you either chocolate
chip cookie you're riding [__]
gasoline into the fire right right it's
just sugar to anxiety yeah it's
somewhere along the line they meet and
it gets more intense oh Jesus when then
I got really high my wife bought Oreos
never be in this room well I was [__]
Oreos who doesn't like Oreos yeah but
again I'm a fat [__] you cut yourself a
deal you're gonna you know what I can
either eat the whole box or I eat seven
that's right I ate all seven of them and
I stopped oh you did oh yeah I'm really
good like that I make a deal like this
there's 92 of them I want seven
hmm and you did it and I did it I could
never do that but between the sugar and
the edible yeah they met somewhere and
it sent me into this [__]
pre-diabetic [__] I don't even have
diabetes I had to go to bed I passed out
oh my God like I passed I woke up at
four thirsty with [__] chocolate in
my mouth and [__]
well I I think
I think side of me that that doesn't
want to be
of control
there's something
I don't know I don't know if people I'm
gonna tell you something okay tell me a
friend of mine
said to me I noticed some stuff about
you take these things
I brought them home they're tremendous
they're baby little volumes they're for
anxiety
before I go home I don't want no drama
sometimes I pop a half of one they're
great
they build a resistance quick I'm very
happy I go to the Jujitsu and train
because I sweat a lot with the ghee you
swell extra so that that pill doesn't
get to sit in your fat yeah but you're
just a regular fat guy in those pillows
half of those pills saying you're fat
right so sometimes you might get tired
in the afternoon you might smoke a half
a number and get tired it's because the
reefer kicked off those [__] pills so
what I try to do is I try to eat those
pills maybe
like tonight if I had to leave early
tomorrow I'd be popping two of those
pills tonight but let me tell you
something
and this is what America doesn't know in
America might think I'm lying to you
I sleep a lot better on these [__]
stars
come when I do one of those pills
I made a deep sleep a deep deep sleep
that you get up at five and you pee you
pee is a little purple it has a weird
stink to it
but you get a handful of [__] water
and you go right back to bed and you
wake up and nothing's sore
wow well sometimes those pills what I
didn't like about medical pills was The
Hangover in the morning yeah I don't
know how people wake up after they top
pop two pills I don't know how people do
it I don't know how people me I'm a
[__] uh
I don't know what you call that it is a
pseudo control freak I don't ever want
to wake up and lose control yeah I
always want to be awake ready
to go yeah I had friends that would sit
down
drink a pot of coffee and
we gotta smoke a pack of cigarettes and
meanwhile it's nine [__] o'clock
do you know how many [__] you
could have mugged from 7 30 to 9 and
you're sitting there smoking [__]
cigarettes people walking into their
offices we're gonna walk in that night
they show an hour to get kicked up get
your paperwork the computer you go and
see you know what I'm saying like I
never understood those people that just
sat there in the mornings I have a
system I get up I [__] drink some
coffee I talked to my wife for a little
while I washed my [__] I get on the
computer I tweet and the baby I sit with
her we watch cartoons I feed I make a
chocolate milk you know I can't imagine
just laying in bed and rubbing your feet
and thinking about your life and where
it's gone [__] you you got to get up and
go [__] yeah and you know I read
about people with pills that are on pill
problems and I wish they could and then
people always go with Joey you make it
sound so easy yeah I don't care where
you live I don't care if you live in
Tennessee and they got laws against
wheat there's nothing against the law
against you going home cooking that weed
up melting with butter taking the butter
out and putting it in brownies and
putting a tray of brownies putting in
the freezer cutting it into little
[__] hands people do it all the
[__] time out here and you eat one
before you go to yoga or before you
[__] go to sleep and you sleep like a
goddamn baby or after you work out it
takes the asses out of your muscles
really yeah a lot of people will know
that [__] no I did not Dr Joey who the
[__] you think you're dealing with a
joey bananas
the reason when you're on the show I
really want to get on the show was
like I said uh they've had the
discussion about women and comedy and
you know we could sit here for a [__]
Thousand Nights and talk about a
women who sit there and complain about
the set list at The Improv and whatever
and then you can talk about the women
that go out every night and do four
[__] spots yeah there's always a spot
this flap is there's the ha ha actually
Flappers is what I was talking about
there's a gas station out the [__]
corner there's a pizza place you can you
can even do two sets of shitty places
just to get your timing and the words
yeah I have written some of my favorite
punch lines at shitty
rooms because there's nobody there
because there's nobody there do you
remember the stove pepper
it's deep in the valley it's kind of
like between here and and Northridge
and it was a bar you walked in it was
red all the lights were red you just
walked into like a furnace and it wasn't
a terrible room but it was just like you
know it was just like a kind of a little
bit of a [__] up room you know people
in the back all the comics are talking
the people at the bar
a lot of distractions but there were
some regulars that were there for for
the comedy show and it wasn't the worst
but it definitely had some faults but I
wrote two or three of my favorite punch
lines at the stove Piper
just this crappy little room on a
Thursday night deep in the valley
you don't have to do it on a Saturday at
the Laugh Factory in front of Industry
that's actually when I don't I don't
feel like I can even really
be vulnerable at the laugh factor on a
Saturday I just want to go in and I just
want to kill I want to do a great job
but that's
the shitty rooms are the ones where it's
like 10 people and I actually find out
oh this is what the joke is oh okay I
figured it out here let me now go take
it and put it on a you know a stage on a
Saturday
in front of people that are you know
paid 20 bucks to get in
it's
so weird how
I do not like comedy in a way for people
six years of them during comedy
I do not like it why not tell me because
it's like my youth
say Michael Jackson's youth you
when I was a kid when I was 10 I already
knew [__] the kid 16 didn't [__] know
you know when I was uh when Michael
Jackson's big
you know claimed to fame was that he
didn't have a childhood yeah and I got
it you know you've seen it he saw behind
the record label he saw how they treated
him and years later in effect on him I
understand
uh what was the topic
people who uh have been doing stand up
less than six years six years
some of my best times in my [__] life
awake my it was my comedy career zero to
six years
if Akira if we didn't have to make money
doing this how much fun would comedy
really be if I told you here I'm going
to give you a job you're going to make a
buck and a quarter a year and we're
gonna give you raises every year
but I want you as part of this job you
have to go out every night four nights a
week and do 10 minutes a mile from your
house yeah have fun with your life be in
like a bar yeah people laughing hanging
out no money you don't care about how
many people show up right you don't
worry about your managers who's the
agent you have a day job you have a day
job you're doing this as a form of honey
I don't go to the gym I don't go to yoga
you know I cook I I just want to go out
I'll be home by 10 30. because that's
all it really is you're home by 10 30 in
those days yeah you sign up at the list
today I gotta be honest with you as a
human being I remember like going to
summer camp to basketball camp or finger
banging whenever behind McKinley School
when she had a chili Catholic suit on
let me tell you something you finger
bang a girl she's got a Catholic School
school suit on you've arrived as a man
oh dude I've done it as a woman you need
a finger chick you finger the chick with
a Catholics girl suit on you're
following I mean there's different
things that you remember in your life
and I got Jason the First Years first
six years of my comedy was so hard and
so
outlandish yeah but I cherish those
first years with [__] everything and
I can't believe how many little things
little things turned into big things I
haven't been getting to [__] Detroit
with a box
like with two inches of quarters dimes
and nickels
and getting there and realizing
there's no show on Wednesday night
so what did you do on the joint
and a box full of change
what was the change for
just when you go into a gas station and
you give them a 20 and they give you
eighteen dollars
and 82 cents you get to change oh I see
I see just a box of chains yeah yeah
yeah
well you know I uh I actually had a very
interesting conversation I'm not gonna
tell you who it is because I don't want
to make him feel bad but a uh a guy who
is in the industry decided to do stand
up had me on his podcast
and uh so I'm a guest
on his podcast and within the first few
minutes
um I might have already told you this
story I can't remember maybe do you have
a good memory no I'm like very high I
I don't remember though I I don't
remember you saying he he basically said
you know you got into comedy like a lot
of chicks do to to get you know to bang
basically just to get [__] right just
to like go have sex on the road
and I said uh no no that's not why do
you remember the story at all no no no
no that's that's definitely not what
women do on the road
maybe one percent of female Comics but
no I mean I understand a lot of guys do
get into stand up or did whatever like
musicians just to get [__] I get it I
get it but that's not what women do do
you know how dangerous it is to pick up
a guy after your show and uh take them
back to your hotel room that's [__]
that's the scariest
idea in the world to most female Comics
not all I'm sure there are women that do
it but that's really [__] up and he
just kept pushing and pushing and goes
come on you sleep around when you were
single you [__] people on the road no
I didn't first of all when you're a
woman on stage and you have opinions and
you're commanding an audience full of
strangers and making them laugh no
dude's dick is hard that is not how to
get a guy's dick hard I mean most guys
are like oh I don't want to [__] with
that that's a chick who has like a mouth
on her you know most guys again there
are exceptions but he fought me on this
and he just kept telling me and kept
telling me and kept telling me I was
wrong in something that I've been doing
for 17 years
okay all right I guess you know better
but
that that's just one aspect of being a
woman in comedy is it's not the same on
that level
for us in the sense of like hooking up
and
you know taking some guy back to your
hotel room I mean that's the scariest
thing they can kill you
I mean that's Louis CK's bit you know
what his bit is that women have to fear
you know you know who kills women the
most men
that's who killed that I'm [__] his
joke up I'm totally butchering it but
the essence of his joke is you know who
they should be scared of us
we kill women more than anything else
more than a heart disease more than
diabetes it's men and that's so true
so true
I don't like listen I have my problems
with [__] women we all do you know
what I'm saying women have problems with
guys women all do there's some issues
whatever you go Jesus [__] Christ
the last couple [__] years it's been
up more than ever women in comedy one
guy said and got fired this guy this guy
Jerry Lewis
I I never even thought about it like I
was always like you know what
I know what I went through as a comic
and
I know what women go through the reason
your [__] friend is ignorant the guy
that had that podcast yeah because any
[__] comic knows if a chick sucked
dick for that many leaves she'll never
make it to 17 18 years those chicks
disappear yeah I seen those chicks come
and go they're hot they're funny in the
beginning
they hook up with a comedian he writes
that it's an ugly cycle and you see him
years later now they're writing but who
the [__] you know what [__] happened
okay yeah you just couldn't [__] cut
it because you depended on somebody else
and then this is a very small percent
where you've Fallen women that get into
comedy and life happens
life happens but they stay true to being
a comic yeah and they never lose focus
and
they don't use having the kid as an
excuse or you know and I get it I I
listen man I see it I my wife was the
best oh I'm gonna work full-time and
I kept looking at it going okay
and then after two weeks she went to 30
weeks 30 hours
so after another week she went to 20
years yeah and somebody got a raise and
she was like I've been working here for
10 years I'm quitting my job yeah and
the bottom line was that little baby
yeah where the [__] wants to leave their
[__] kid at 7 30 and [__] you I was
like quit that [__] job be a mom
you're 46. what is this gonna happen
again yeah not my [__] lifetime not
my [__] lifetime you're gonna spit
another kid out of 40 [__] nine or
something so oh my God you know I'm
Spanish that's promising would be good
in the casket you know how some people
leave their eyes to society and their
ears and [__] I'm gonna leave my [__]
nut sack and you got 24 hours and I
guarantee you there's 18 [__] kids
swimming around my nutsack I'm Spanish
dog I'm [__] Spanish that [__]
lasting there Theo Von's dad had him
when he was 72. that's right and [__]
you know and then when he told me he's
half Spanish I go ah yeah there's a girl
I know her father's banging somebody in
Puerto Rico knocked her up twice in the
70s that Spanish sperm they eat those
[__] beans that black beans and that
rice that was being stale I'm telling
you I got on my ID [__] I'm keeping in
the eyes take the nut sack that's your
best bet there's 18 kids in there right
now
it's Puerto Rican is he really no no
[__] yeah yeah oh yeah you're gonna be
knocked up to your 90. oh God no I had
my uh my my kid it was now five at the
time he was uh
three and a half
when I found out I was pregnant with the
second one
I peed on one of those sticks you know
and then I had my my kid I go here give
this to Daddy when he walks through the
door when he comes home
we we we're talking about having other
kids so it wasn't that big of a surprise
but
he walks away goes Daddy I have
something for you and he hands my
husband a little stick that you pee on
and he looks down on it he looks at me
and he goes I'm getting snipped
no he hasn't I don't want him to not
because I want more kids but that just
seems Extreme as I cut the neck cat's
nails that's just extreme imagine
jerking off and no it's like it's like
jerking off skim milk it just comes out
of your little dick and little shovels
yeah no but I think because he's like
I'm Puerto Rican you know this is what
we're made to do is made to have babies
and I go it's just relax we planned this
we tried for another one we were having
sex for years before we had our first
kid we'll be fine don't worry how'd you
meet a Puerto Rican husband here in L.A
I thought you had like an Armenian
tucked away that you smacked around and
[__] no you're a strong woman I can't
see you with a Spanish guy very good for
you you're in L.A so you're in a real
[__] deal aren't you yeah no you guys
go to that Puerto Rican restaurant
Lancashire yes yeah yeah okay yeah okay
we got uh for Easter fungal my Fungo we
went there for Easter they got a Coco
Rico well you know what my husband likes
I'm not a fan of them
um they are the Puerto Rican tamales
they're just
stop
I love a Mexican tamale they put him in
a [__] Leaf yeah it smells bad what
are they called again
um yes yes yes no disrespect the Puerto
Ricans you know I love you I love all I
love Mofongo
anybody knows a good Puerto Rican knows
how to make a pork chop that's how you
listen my why like I said it don't
matter
a good part of this your husband make
pork chops he can cook anything okay he
can cook has he ever made pork chops
right yeah I just bring him pork chops
and watch and watch that that's their
blood do you know what he does do you
know what he does like a [__] boss is
um oh my God I'm so embarrassed I just
forgot it's the ham with the skin that's
all crackly and crispy on top what are
you talking about
oh [__] this is gonna kill me it's this
[__] contact high you guys gave me
I'm usually much sharper than this um
what should I search like Puerto Rican
hands please please please it starts
with a b or something or or an R oh oh
[__] you drink uh mavi
[Music]
don't worry about it we'll get the name
of it but they have a thing called my v
as a tea and when they sell it in New
York it's already got a hole in the top
because you have to let it add and
marinate okay it's a very good tea it's
made from a from a herb but what Puerto
Rico is known for
Puerto Rico is known for this thing
called mamusio the humans call it
they call it oh my God
put in
k-e-n-e
-p-a-s and see what comes up
quenepasa call Mom will see you they
grow when they come
and they come full grown in sept uh
August and Puerto Rico so by September
middle of September you would get them
in the Bronx yeah and then these little
[__] things the trees grow and
they're these little [__] uh
these little [__] trees there grow
these uh
great looking things
they're these little grape looking
things and their boss from Puerto Rico
YouTube there you go oh my God and you
buy them by those little things when
they're green right there oh
[__] right there
about to use two of them in my smoothie
have you been to Puerto Rico a thousand
times thousand times until 1980 and then
I haven't been back really
yeah we used to go to Dorado beach one
thing about Puerto Rico do you go back
now I have never been here
that's kind of scary is it yeah why
problems there it's probably they have a
go back let's see if they show the
inside of it you cut that skin off with
your mouth yeah so you pull it off the
[__] Branch you stick it in your
mouth and you cut it you learn how to
cut it with your teeth right you peel it
you spit the shell out okay you just put
that ball in the side of your mouth and
it's got hair on it it's like a sweet
[__] juice
what happened was after 9 11 they
[__] stopped letting people bring
them in like you could there you go oh
[__] it looks like a [__] [__] that
thing look at it it's nice and soft and
gooey like a [__] Lisa yet look
at that [__]
and so they're sweet very sweet and you
just suck it until the hair is all gone
it's just a season you think I'm [__]
kidding you who the [__] you think
you're dealing with here
if you can't even Mama see you
definitely not gonna eat nobody's [__]
you follow me that's just the perfect
rule oh my God suck it until the hair is
all gone that's
he can cook I'll tell you right now
amazing it really yeah he he's that
that's one thing that I'm so grateful I
don't have to do those are some wifey
duties I don't have to do because he
even tells me he goes I go let me make
you some eggs or let me make you
something he goes please let me just do
it like he doesn't even want me to I'm
not terrible but it doesn't compare to
what he can do like even eggs he makes
okay though he puts butter spices in
eggs and eggs he makes scrambled eggs
any kind anything whatever but he uses
like Spanish people don't put food
nobody else dopes up food you gotta dope
food up you gotta dope it up you just
can't put listen yeah you could put salt
and pepper on a steak that's great but
you want to make a little better throw
some garlic pot on that [__] you
know what I'm saying let me give some
shout outs real quick John I'll give me
Jeff Talon man nasty Doctor Lisa Willis
Clark Canfield Timmy the Turtle
let's talk fights
and Crystal [__] Johnson
a little shout out to you [__]
Savages
getting your [__] together Lee Syed
eating 725 tonight
so what are you doing this weekend
you're going to visit your rant San
Francisco she died you're not going up
there what happened you said flowers
yeah yeah the funerals you said flowers
no my dad what happened so your dad was
there we just sent flowers no no because
I'm going on Sunday you are gone yeah
well not to San Francisco I'm going to
there's a thing in in uh on the beach
somewhere
so because it was today at two so I
couldn't protecting your girlfriend with
you yeah she's gonna go out of respect
and it's actually it's a it's very nice
that you're here tonight because he
wrote like you're very similar to her
like she's she was my aunt so she was
this is your dad's sister uh no a dad's
uh I guess maybe she was a cousin she's
dead she's my dad's cousins yeah she's
my dad Dad's cousin but she's basically
my mom well you know in Russian um the
word for cousin is the same as the word
for sister okay so there it's considered
even if it's your Dad's cousin it's like
his sister yeah
I'm gonna do that but she it was uh she
was a great lady but it's not it's it's
good it was she was in pain so um but
anyways I'm gonna have a good weekend
other than that
oh [__] Indianapolis this weekend
tickets are selling fast
don't [__] around the stars are already
landed I got the call at 3 30 today
that the stars of debt were already in
Annapolis ready for me to [__] eat
when I get there in the hotel what are
you looking forward to in Indianapolis
like rest and relaxation I gotta do a
lot of [__] writing for four [__]
days
so I gotta write a lot this week and I
gotta have something ready by Monday at
least on paper what do you have to write
I gotta write a pilot for somebody and
they want to see and I got everything on
yeah ready yeah I just have to write it
according to the paperwork they gave me
yeah
so if I can do that it's not something
I'm selling or not I'm just doing an
exercise yeah so um that's what I'm
doing this weekend I'm gonna start
tomorrow on the flight what do you think
your pilot would be called
suck my dick and call me shorty okay I
was born in 1940. no no no this isn't uh
this isn't even that type of pilot to be
honest here somebody just came to me and
said just give me an idea I have an idea
for this what do you think fill in the
blanks for me so I said you know what
it's a muscle
I need to work anyway
we don't want to play for [__] hours
how many times can you watch concussion
how many times can you watch the first
pilot in the first episode of vinyl
right you know so you how many times can
I listen to the same oh [__] oh it's
plugging in don't let me [__] forget
the iPod how many times was the same
music on the iPod so sometimes I get
high and I get down the plane I go you
know what let me pull the computer out I
pull a notebook out and if I could write
for an hour and a half until I get
impatient
it's not a bad move for Uncle Joey you
know what I'm saying so and it's just a
good muscle to have that years ago I
never had I had the ideas but now I know
how to put them together
what do you think about people who do a
new special every year and have to write
and then they get rid of that material
they have to write all brand new
material
that's the game yeah
that's the game right now I'm in hell
I'm doing half new and half old
because I have to write a special so
you're trying to write a special
it's a [__] difficult job
because here's the problem okay so you
write a special while you're writing a
special you're on the [__] road yeah
putting all the touches to it
yeah you come that way and you go to
Flappers and you go to the store and you
go to this place and go to that place
but let me tell you something 50 minutes
is 50 [__] minutes
you could write chunks
you follow me you can write chunks of
[__] and put 20 minutes together but to
really flow it together it's like a
training camp I feel
for you to have a matter you know I saw
Chris Rock in the old days I saw Chris
Rock
go out Thursday Friday Saturday
but Monday Tuesday Wednesday
he would uh
he would uh Monday Tuesday and Wednesday
he would get rich and Jenny
Louis CK and Nick De Paula
and on Monday nights they would start to
laugh at you Latino man and Chris Rock
we're going there and he'd do 15 minutes
and then they get in their car and they
rush to the Improv
and then he'd do 15 minutes said and
Richard Jenny would give him notes
oh they're giving him notes and then he
would go to
uh whatever the [__] it was
now do you think okay that's Chris Rock
because he can get up anywhere in town
right he can go to any club
can I just say the world can I just say
if he went into into a club in London
they would let him on and if he went
into a club in Amsterdam they would let
him on probably right they might not
believe it's him but they would let him
on
he can probably write a new hour in a
year okay but he would get let's say
he'd get 250 000 advance
from whatever
he gets Karma Lee and me and he goes 50
Grand a piece
I need 15 minutes
I'm talking about don't hold back here
give me a ten fifty thousand dollars
the next six weeks you putting your
career in low for me oh everything you
write for Uncle Joey right is gonna be
what
you you know what I'm saying like this
is it so
um
that's a smart way yes I know Comics
that do that I get it I get it but do
you so okay I myself I myself
don't think
a comic personally myself and my world
could have a part a one year
a new hour
I don't either unless I [__] go out
three weeks
a month and
while I'm here I'm out three or four
nights yeah doing 20 minute chunks yeah
so I would do 15 minute chunks what I
would do is just break my 45 minutes
into three minute chunks
and go to Flappers Monday haha Tuesday
right right about Wednesday yeah that's
one you have to just turn into a machine
you have to turn into a machine in the
daytime you have to write and you have
to listen to that tape yeah like one
thing I went through whatever last
weekend put the not once every night I
go tonight I'm gonna tape this set and I
[__] once that I tape and it's such a
bad habit but I know for me it's even
more painful to hear that [__] tape
me too it's painful to hear my voice
it's painful to hear my stupid jokes
it's painful so now here's the other
dilemma so now we
Joe Diaz and Kay and Felicia and legal
out every night four nights a week you
go on the road do your material blah
blah you get an hour come November you
put your hour down guess what happens in
December
you got to go out
what material are you doing
you have no material the same one from
the [__] special they saw the special
and they saw you developing the [__]
jokes so now what about those six months
you just developed those materials those
are your fans
they're gonna you're gonna shoot your
special October it comes out on [__]
January
and here you are they're gonna go and
they're gonna go he did that material in
Chicago he did that material in [__]
Cincinnati yeah so it's a really tough
job people to put this together a
special right now is
a tough job if you have help if you have
somebody putting makeup on you and
picking your wardrobe when I did my
special I didn't like a Puerto Rican
that's why it didn't work out we were
talking at the beginning of the podcast
of people
you learn from other people's mistakes
yeah we talked about people who shoot
their own Pilots I gotta I I pitch CBS I
pitch Fox I pitch [__] NBC and I
pitched ABC and didn't like my idea [__]
them my bro I know people who have told
me this in 99 my family refinanced the
house and we got 300K we're gonna shoot
our own pilot and them having a party
you know that place next to coaching
horses down the corner
it's like if you have a Premiere and
you're a [__] half a [__] yum and
you have no dough they let you do it
there yeah
they had cocktails and bartenders I'll
never forget going and I went not as a
judgmental person I went what just to
see
when I went to that [__] thing and
they've shown that pilot hey it was
[__] terrible but then I watched the
[__] white people who hung out
afterwards and all the people that were
lying to this couple and you know she
was about to sign with somebody's
manager and they already had a buyer for
the pilot who knew the same guy who did
Darwin Greg and you know
about three years ago IMDb those people
that's the last thing they did yeah they
packed up their bags and left with a
three hundred thousand dollar [__]
hoe and how many people shot their own
TV Pilots because nobody picked it up
we're gonna sell it ourselves at least
40. wow I just saw a chick on that
[__] show with the Chinese people on
ABC that shot her own pilot and came to
me and asked me to shoot it that she had
a boyfriend that was at ABC and they
were going to pick up the pilot
that girl was one of them and she used
somebody else and they didn't pay him
and there was a problem yeah those
things were always a [__] nightmare
yeah look I just shot my own special and
uh I it's
at least that's something that's gonna
that's going to air but man
to do it all on your own
it's bananas
are you going what was so difficult
about it well because
not only did I have to get investors I
had to crowdfund that was the last time
I was here I got look I better make some
money on this thing so I got the Russian
mob they put money into it they don't
[__] around you know so it's like
uh hi
um you know it's hard it's hard it is
hard but that's different than a pilot
I made it stress-free and that's why the
special failed
because I didn't put enough pressure on
myself yeah because I knew the odds in
the back of my mind were gonna be tough
whether I was an assault than Netflix
whatever the [__] I was gonna sell it to
so
I knew going in that I was working
against tide and when we brought it back
and we put it together I looked at it in
the first five minutes I go shut up
I knew right off the bat and I wanted to
smack myself in the face I lost the
money the investment myself but
some you know this is this is the big
boy League sometimes you gotta take a
beating to learn yeah showed me
something you don't want to put out
something that you're not proud of yeah
no no no no no no no and you know when I
could have put it on pieces and made
stories up forget it just leave it the
[__] alone just forget about it it's not
gonna work out what's up dog what's up
beautiful
look at you got the nice shoes on today
a little [__] Johnny Capezio out of
respect for [__] Prince
[__] you think you're dealing with
Felicia went deep in the closet tonight
she said I'm busting the [__]
capezios at you know what I'm saying I
have never seen Felicia not look on
point
it's a scary [__] proposition not
once not once
well
yeah but if we could combine the two of
us to a super power
yeah you know man uh being a woman is a
tough [__] job you know
and all these women have beauty secrets
and [__] and the Beauty secret is water
sleep and don't get [__] married I
stay beautiful for a long [__] time
okay you know no offense I know you're
married man I know my wife is married
but yeah you look at women you don't
know the [__] formula and in
Hollywood today what's the formula they
chopped my face up to look like a
[__] Martian to shoot something now
you're in a room full of eight other
martians looking at each other sending
each other's space signals and [__]
but at the end of the day it's it's
you know the [__] water walking
around breathing
and just being stressed [__] Free as
a woman look at the women of the women
of the smoking crack that's a stressful
job they lose their feet they got a
bunch of [__] wrinkles
the crack wrinkles are the hardest
because
nothing it's
stuff with crack wrinkles
no the reason why I and go to the Korean
baths can we add that to the list please
please can we add that to you know that
I'm a I'm an addict right we should
what you go
oh I go all the time Jackie cation won't
go with me but I know she goes behind my
back she'll tweet when she's at a Korean
spa I'm here naked thinking of you
really and I tweet this I tweet too I go
hey Jackie I'm at a Korean spa naked
thinking of you
I love it I think it's it's going to be
on your list please I'll try it okay no
no on your list that you just listed
drink water walk around oh breathe
Koreans go to a Korean [__] spot get
a little massage a little circulation
through your legs and [__] avoid the
varicoseable veins yeah that's the whole
[__] thing you know it's tough to
give a [__] when you got a varicose
brain on your ass you know what I'm
saying I mean look unless the varicose
vein is something sexy you know that's
right mine are not unfortunate they look
like traffic on the 405 you know and
your map is all just red
I look at these kids and I'm like [__]
[__] you sold the
special to all these streaming sites
here did you do this all yourself
that was in blast at them and I had a
manager who made two phone calls right
they're not gonna do that and he said I
got two no's
and I go okay so what I get nose all the
time and he goes I don't know I don't
know if he can sell I got two no's it's
probably can't sell
and they said a couple other things that
were not very nice so uh you got rid of
them I had to get rid of them and sell
it myself he probably couldn't even get
his foot to the [__] door I know I
know you probably even look at the
special that's the hard thing that yeah
half of these guys I had to do it myself
I figured I'm already doing everything
else to myself I made the baby well I
had my husband's help but you know I'm
doing it all I might as well just I'm
not saying like in a martyr type of way
I'm just like all right let's just get
this done
you know what I mean it's just like
let's just get this done so I'll just do
it I applaud you for shooting
because just putting together a special
you shot it pregnant you shot it
GoFundMe and not like a week pregnant it
was like yeah no no you were really a
[__] boss pregnant get oh my God your
water could have broke right there that
must have been stressful it might as
well have broken because I peed the
entire time
I'm not joking I'm not joking I wish I
was joking the entire time I was pissing
myself
because when you're pregnant you have to
pee every 20 minutes right what would
you do you put a girdle on a girl no I
didn't put a girdle on I'm pissed I
pissed you got off the station pissed no
you put the Peds on no where'd you
[__] piss just where I was standing
on stage well yes I had to The Show Must
Go On Joey so you're telling me when I'm
watching this show yes every 20 minutes
you're gonna bend over and pee no I'm
not gonna bend over okay we're just
telling jokes okay when does the p come
out well you got to look closely are you
serious
cereal look when you have to pee and
you're pregnant it's just it's I when
you shoot a special for Showtime right
when I shot my Showtime special they
gave me a 12 o'clock call time getting
hair and makeup at 12 30 get on stage at
one shoot your special and then go home
right when you're doing it yourself
right I was there at 10 A.M helping
organize everything and they hang the
lights and we had to create a whole
stage and I mean we had to create a
stage in this venue and then I'm on at
8pm so I'm running around I'm drinking
lots of water to stay hydrated I forget
to pee here I am on stage and my body's
like ah now we can relax
so watch the special
I don't know if I'm watching the special
do I see a puddle in the front of your
legs I don't know what you give HD I
don't know what you're watching it on
you watch it on your iPhone maybe not
if you got like a you know movie movie
theater in your house maybe I don't know
I don't know what you're gonna see I'm
just telling you that's the honest truth
I can only be honest I actually met with
my director today we had lunch and I go
look I'm gonna tell people what honestly
happened during the special he goes
knock yourself out because he knows I
was peeing the whole time
okay
where's the [__] P gold Kyra
sultanovic with the [__] people it
was magic it was magic did you have a
depend on no I don't even think I was
wearing underwear
[Laughter]
[Music]
why do you say this [__] that's just the
truth I don't want to lie this is just
the truth look a lot of people are
special thankfully just black pants a
lot of people want to like come on and
say like everything worked out perfectly
no it was [__] up there was a baby in
the front row someone brought a [__]
baby to my special
a baby and if you look closely again you
see the baby the camera cat front row
and this is Orange County so they were a
very nice black couple with this very
cute black baby with little Pom-Pom
ponytails on the side of her face she
was adorable but I can't very well tell
the only black people to get to the back
of the room
right Orange County I can't say that so
there they are in my special babies
crying I mean it was [__] up
in June or July but
it It's just sometimes they don't happen
perfectly I can relate to you when you
shot yours and you're like what the [__]
oh I know five people who shot
Specialists and they're like what
happened yeah you don't want but I can
know that I was too invested I'm not
kidding there is Russian mob money in
this special I have to pay it back I
like my fingers
so people better [__] watch all right
so when does it Premiere next two
seconds Monday Monday Monday the second
month what time midnight Sunday I don't
know how it works that's a really good
question I don't know how these this is
a whole new world right like I don't
know when things Premiere I know like
probably when I watch shows on Amazon
they just appear on my Amazon when
they're supposed to be there
they just appear so maybe it's like
Monday morning I don't know what morning
is I don't know but it'll be there
it'll be it'll be on video on demand
it'll be on Dish Network
anywhere you get streaming content this
is uh it's out it's it's happening
command those down no manage no agent
nobody behind you no manager no agent no
underwear
I'm a Puerto Rican husband at home
Puerto Rican two Puerto Rican babies I
have contributed to the Browning of
society you're welcome America what's
your skin tone like is it great
you know what my son is looks more
Latino than the the new baby
I don't know who she is
I don't know what this new baby's all
about how old is she now she's eight
months beautiful
I'm crazy about this kid I'm crazy about
her
I just I take her and I squeeze her way
too tight
way too tight it's borderline like all
right relax relax I just I just I'm
crazy about her
but they also you know
they also [__] block your careers they
do
it's okay
they give you a different career
that's what it is figure they give you a
different career
um you know I had some moms over for a
comedian's baby shower I wasn't gonna do
a baby shower for the second baby right
because we got all the [__] right so we
had some moms over and there were a
couple that never had kids and uh you
know them
they were angry they were angry they
were like Mitzi told us never to have
kids so we listened to Mitzi
it's a different career you know you
have you get a different career when you
have them right Felicia you can relate
yes
yes in my world
has been really [__] exciting for me
like
I don't know what I'd do at this point
without it yeah like it's that [__]
much like
I'm in yeah like I'm really here
I don't really give a [__] about
anything
like she's it
but don't you feel like your drive
changed because it's not just about you
yeah yeah oh yeah when I leave the
[__] house and I got a gun on me all
[__] day like no you really gotta
it really did because I like what's
going on so I want this yeah
uh you know the baby's happy the wife is
happy so you know what my five-year-old
said to me he goes mommy can you try
harder in your career so we can have a
big backyard
Jesus Christ
I was like how many dick jokes do I have
to tell to get this kid back here you
[__] work we had this conversation at
dinner that night that
you work and
this town sometimes has a weird way
of rewarding people that really work in
a weird way yeah you know we have so
many outlets now
that people like you never lose
there are so many outlets going on for
people right now if you really want it
you don't lose yeah right now there's a
kid in Indiana and Indiana
saying man I love that I love comedy you
know what I'm gonna put a brick wall
here
and he's gonna [__] put a [__]
GoPro on the wall and he's gonna tap
into Periscope and every night
that's how Johnny could you know you
never [__] know right this kid's
gonna transmit all over the world from a
[__] wall like this that cost you 35
[__] dollars you know a brick wall
and that's how easy it is you don't need
anybody today nothing
there's an app on that [__] computer
you stay up tonight that you can
pay-per-view an event
you could pay-per-view in a [__]
event right now and start with zero and
every week go up there and go you're
missing life 44.95 and you'll get two
and then you'll get four and then you'll
get eight and it's 44.95 that's what
fights are you know HD 44 they don't
know whether and eventually people start
going on a Friday night and going I'm
not saying you could charge 44 hours
right but my point is if you had a
[__] thing that came up to you you
know and and there's got to be a search
engine
that you go people who stay home and
smoke dope
you know people have taken surveys that
they enjoy staying home or smoking dope
or people that watch a lot of YouTube
videos or something there's got to be
something that you can measure people's
computer by YouTube It's and get a
message to them and say hey there's a
Pay-Per-View event tonight yeah
comedians
from the Ice House five hours
how many [__] people comedy clubs are
thinking about that right now going
should we say something before somebody
else says something yeah
or [__] should we just wait for some
[__] genius
to go [__] going out to comedy clubs for
eight dollars a month
you can watch Comedy [__] live every
Friday night from your [__] house but
here's the issue though how would you uh
deal with the new content because if
you're doing it every week from on the
internet people can watch anywhere that
eliminates touring
people are home
people at home so what do you say like
you'll just be like it's the same act
what are you like [__] Noli what are
you gonna ask me these stupid questions
who gives a [__] I'm just saying four
[__] people for five dollars on a
Friday night from eight to [__] ten
live on your computer on your Apple TV
you pay five dollars on PayPal right and
boom it comes up you they don't need to
know who the [__] it is the more you
tell them the least you're gonna get
this is what I'm saying they don't need
to know dick nothing stand-up comedy for
comedians five [__] dollars how long
till you start selling two thousand of
those on Friday night at five [__]
dollars because the word gets out you
know what I'm saying David tell what are
you doing Friday night you're in La
anyway we you know you ever go to Garden
stages
you're going to guard the stages
downstairs
please the [__] Thai place the the
Thai place on across around the corner
it's disgusting you go downstairs you
get 14 15 [__] they didn't comedy
they've been years uh 11 o'clock that
kid they even taped the [__] show
that kid that comes on at one o'clock
and talks about music and bands he comes
on NBC what the [__] is his name
Carson Daly Carson Daly used to go there
on Friday nights and they would do
comedy there and he'd tape it all it
seats is 40 people okay who gives a [__]
yeah you think the people who Garden
stage people won't even know what the
[__] you're doing you don't even have to
go in there with big cameras you go in
there with [__] you get some genius
to put a splitter together and get six
or three GoPros right on periscope
right on [__] Periscope yeah he was
telling me that there's women on
Periscope they show you that [__] for
money
so that's already going on on [__]
Periscope well that was a matter of time
I mean comedy's [__] next comedies
how do you charge people on Periscope
Lee how are they doing well um you have
to buy tickets or cookies or some [__]
well then right you got to buy something
weird they had a scam already
right now there's a [__] kid going to
win this thing I live in Sherman Oaks
you know what you should do you know
those cam sites where like the girls get
naked that's it same dude comedy on
there do I just do it right on there
because they already get they get coins
just overtake if there's people who sit
at home and play video games and people
pay them to watch them play [__]
video games they're rich kids okay
same thing you just keep throwing people
up in a room coming to the stage flam
bam thank you ma'am it goes up there
lights himself off why if you like the
ACT put money in the Box just like Jerry
Lewis and his [__] Telethon
same difference
eventually it's gonna [__] happen
some slick ass is gonna go you know what
yeah I had an idea for a show they gave
it to Steve whatever Hostetler he got
glass that we're gonna do I don't
[__] laps at 11 o'clock at night on
Saturday and go ahead and from a cave in
Hollywood and let's see who [__]
shows up with five dollars there's a
thousand caves in Hollywood thousands by
Schrader yeah all those wild streets
there's thousands of rooms guys you
don't know about yeah what was that
girl's name that used to do a Japanese
restaurant on coagen
you [__] giggle about over there
remember and it got big too
eight years ago that was a whole
Japanese restaurant yes it was an old
Mafia Japanese restaurant in La sushi
they so sake and that's it [__]
that's all you get we don't have
crackers here I do remember do you
remember all those little rooms that are
still there like now Stout's there and
there's a bunch of right right before
Seven's there and they changed Houston's
and all that [__]
um I remember there there was a place
right where I think it was an Italian
restaurant that was also like in the in
the basement
that um
was Michelle's was it michelli's yeah
upstairs or downstairs on Sunday nights
yes and then on eyeball that little
theater on the corner yeah they had
comedy and on Saturday nights at 11.
they paid 37.50 or some [__] you got to
get your 37.50 the Chili's was packed
every time yeah yeah this is 10 years
ago yeah much more Mike used to host it
he was an afritated he was a boxer he
got a place in the head a couple times
you got to be careful around him and
[__] he was also a waiter he's not there
no more something happened I don't know
what the [__] happened
nah man listen when I saw
you see uh every 90 days you see
somebody on Facebook and Twitter at
shooting they're at home [__]
smash yeah [__] Netflix and those punk
ass [__] yeah and they shoot their
own special and it's very seldom that
you see a follow-up
he get laid the same it's edited cut and
it's ready to review so yeah uh
especially in the world today where
everybody's uh
taking shots of [__] female comics
and [__] like that they're not getting
enough spots and not doing nothing
it's true you know it's the truth so you
just say [__] this [__] no I'm gonna do
my own special I don't need an Asian I
don't need a [__] manager
honey none of these [__] so
it's great to see it man so thank you
police is going to shoot my next
question we're gonna shoot it right in
this [__] against the flag five
dollar pay-per-view amen 50 minutes is
50 minutes I'm telling you guys this
club owner is going
yeah I don't know
but a club owner better jump on that
racket before a civilian jumps on it
and says and there's Comics that aren't
working that'll [__] do that [__] oh
yeah those people who come on Steve
Outlets to the show I've never seen that
one of those people I know not one of
those people have I seen at a club and
I'm sorry I try to be hip and I think
they pay the comics anything no well
they took them to court and now they pay
him now they have to pay him like a a
one day yeah shoot free whatever okay 20
the first season they paid the comments
20 bucks
they weren't paying them they weren't
paying yeah no I mean I'm not gonna say
not at all because I read the article
like years ago but they would look very
low if they painted the money yeah I
think it was like 20 bucks
the executive producer like just said
like it's for uh it's to get seen it's
it's exposure the exposure yeah
somebody sued him and I don't know what
they had to pay him after but they got
to give you at least comes on Fox 11
o'clock that's mad tv money yeah so the
same money Mad TV paid they gotta give
you half they have to give you something
you know even there's no comic who she
you know I'm surprised that more reality
stars haven't sued or any real reality
stars haven't sued uh like production
companies oh the contracts they have are
the same like the money that they've
made off of them yeah for the money that
they give them especially it's like they
have stars like Snooki but like I'm
talking about like sea level cable
channel reality shows right so they
don't give them nothing yeah and then
they made it it's crazy with the black
people yelling at each other I love it
one of those [__] shows I see that
all the time a bunch of black women from
Atlanta yelling at each other I don't
even know what the [__] going on oh is
it the housewives one of them the
Basketball Wives oh Basketball Wives
they got like three or four of them or
something but that's even good there's
like terrible like all those channels
that you go through and you skip they
have reality TV and it's not good it's
like like if someone I've worked on some
that were just terrible
Dance Moms I don't know I've never
watched it you know I think when I
started um setting my own parameters
I felt a shift in my career so maybe I
didn't like say it out loud to a lot of
people but if someone wanted me to do a
show let's say an hour away from La in
my mind I knew I'm not going to do it
for less than x amount and I just
started saying no I let me know when you
have a budget and I'll come do your show
that's an hour drive like I started
setting like parameters like if it's an
hour I need to get paid this it's my
time you know if it's if it's further I
need to get paid you know I need to get
none of this like can you come out to
Palm Springs for 70 bucks no no I can't
no nobody should do that unless they are
in Palm Springs
I mean I've done it already I've done it
thank you but it's it comes back to the
whole exposure thing it's like I
appreciate it thank you for calling let
me know when you have more money in your
budget well there's a lot of skinamas
out there and there's right now we live
in a Hollywood where Monday through
Thursday
um
the clubs know that they won't do dick
so what they do is get Independent
Producers yeah which I don't mind at all
it's great for the business
what ticks me off
at any level what ticks me off is that
you have a deal with the Improv you give
away 200 tickets so Felicia Michaels
works hard she has a newspaper article
she's part of a podcast
she's just had a special she's relevant
okay they put Felicia on the show and
Dane Cook
you know they sell the [__] they sell
half the room The Improv gives them six
seven hundred dollars and again
and I hate to say this
I wipe my ass with 100 bucks that you're
gonna give me yeah but do me a favor and
make the [__] effort
take 15 from the seven you're taking I
pay for the guys let me at least you
know what don't give Felicia 50 bucks
give Lee who did seven minutes give him
50 bucks yeah Felicia won't mind that
she's a real comic she knows what it is
to be that [__] guy over there
you know you do these producing rooms
nobody even says thank you
then they call you once a room they put
your name on there with free [__]
tickets
and not even a [__] friendly [__] you
you know what I'm saying like it just
gets to the point where there's a lot of
sneaky [__] people out there yeah I
had a situation years ago like for some
reason for two or three years people
kept calling me for YouTube movies
I had a string of two [__] years that
it was either a YouTube movie
or a hundred dollar a day movie
okay and I just said one day I go you
know what 100 day movies again I'm very
flattered that he thought of me but it's
80 [__] 250 after taxes which I got
to pay an agent 10 bucks number two
right I gotta dry clean my own clothes
and number three
you're gonna shoot at night because
you're so [__] cheap you got to use
like the cemetery across the street at
three in the morning right which means I
don't [__] sleep and I lose a day
usually when you agree to those online
movies guess what happens Thursday you
got three grand Star auditions and they
really want to see you at 10 15. but you
already committed to this jerk off yeah
for a lot of [__] day in the cemetery
and bring the [__] morning that's
when you say you know what next time
somebody calls maybe one of these I'm
not [__] doing it and I did that and
I got a call once and the agent called
me and he goes hey they want to use you
I don't know they were like I'm not
doing it
I'm not [__] doing it and it was a
[__] one-armed MC
what I need this in my life I need this
in my life Alicia I'm smoking dope yeah
they go like put the arm behind you and
they want you to go out there and be
like lurching [__] and I was like listen
I don't want to do it my agent kept
calling me listen they called you from
that movie again
they really want you to [__] do it
they'll throw another arm in if you'll
do it no they'll make you a two-armed
now three arms if you really want you to
do it like I'm not [__] doing it
and then they call back and they go they
want to give you 750 a day it's three
days they promise they'll send a car for
you and you're in and out and I go
listen dog I don't want to [__] do it
it's a really interesting story
a week later they call and they go Joey
they're coming up to the date they don't
want to [__] around what do you want
so I thought about and I said three days
and they said though it's one or eight
hour day one like three hour day
and one like two hour day and I was like
you know where's the shoe you know again
it was like the edge of [__] hell
right from town I never heard of in
between like Bakersfield
and El Segundo you know one of those
towns that you know it's called L.A no
no no no
four hour drive so it's eight hours
that's four each way three and a half
hours there's no airport so it was seven
hours right now no no no no it was like
one of those places where they say to
you do you know where Bakersfield is and
you're like yeah they're like 62 months
in a small town called like El bambo or
something you know one of those things
right and I did the math and I go you
know what
I could really use the money but I made
myself a promise
I thought back to that [__] graveyard
at three in the morning I never want to
feel like that again
call them back I said I asked for five
G's
and they called back and said done
so they had the money they had the money
yeah I'll sleep they always have the
money
they all those online all day movies
they always got the money because they
make the Stars producers
so that that [__] dude that was the
third guy and uh
the movie with Matt Damon and the other
guy that didn't have two [__] lines
in the movie now he's the star of this
one
and he's a producer and the [__]
actor so he gets a double rate and the
producers rate he's there with a smile
on his face and they're bringing him
[__] uh what's he drinking champagne
Cox champagne no he's drinking uh
Starbucks they're bringing him Starbucks
you're sitting there drinking that
communist [__] coffee you know and uh
he's giggling the whole way because he's
making money on this [__] movie
meanwhile you're jumping fences and
getting chased by [__] dogs and [__]
like that so I told him no forget
they're like well Joey they're paying me
I'm gonna have a dog I'm not doing it
I'm not doing it I got comedy that
weekend I mean he's got to call the club
and cancel it for what a movie that's
nobody's ever gonna [__] see let's be
in this [__] face it yeah and before
that I got a call like a week before
that some jerk off about a baseball
movie I can't even say the names of the
people that he had in the movie he
called me to sell me because I got your
name from a chiropractor what the [__]
are you talking about when he told me he
knew you I thought you'd be perfect for
the role
I said send me over the script he goes
it's a great shoot you're gonna shoot
for eight days I go where's the shoot he
goes Utah
and I go dog that's not gonna work I
can't be away from my family for eight
days a day
oh my yeah but it's 900 plus overtime
again
it's nine [__] days
I can't do it no way you shoot three and
send me home for four and I'll come back
but
it's not gonna work no and the guy
called and called and called and he made
me a pretty sweet deal plus he got me a
weekend at the club and Wise Guys yeah
because I called you only he'll give me
the weekend you could do a door deal
and I said you know what I'm not doing a
long day movie
they were pissed and then I down this
other guy the one-armed [__] Bandit
yeah
and I said no and I said you know what
I'm a [__] [__] and a week later I
got the dinero Stallone movie
so
sometimes you make a personal promise to
yourself yeah I didn't say nothing to
Terry I didn't say another Felicia I
didn't say no delete I just said I'm
done with that dog you know what I used
to follow poemly at The Comedy Store at
midnight that means something in my
[__] world just because I don't have
a sitcom and [__] that's my [__]
metal who gave it to me me that's who
[__] gave it to me and you make that
decision and a week later I got the call
for this the long movie where the movie
sucked or not I didn't work for 100 a
day right that was the [__] point I
just said no I don't give a [__] [__] my
insurance it will work out somebody will
[__] high for what you're worth
that's what you said somebody Ohio you
got to see my Facebook I wake up every
morning with six messages four of them
are tremendous deals
you got to see the deals in the office I
get and then you know I'm glad people
think they're doing me a [__] favor
not gonna be no [__] favor I have a
YouTube thing that I wanted you to do
for me
I ain't doing no [__] news
no because that's how listen I didn't
get thrown out of the store
I didn't get thrown out of the store
there's a what's that [__] movie
when they go to [__] Arabia and they
blow the [__] place up and they have
to send the FBI with Jennifer Garner and
and Matt Fox Jamie Foxx and the [__]
English guy goes in there has to torment
that out of the FBI it's a hard game he
goes in Dan he has to torment the guy
from the FBI and tell them why the team
has to go to [__] Saudi Arabia to do
the test on the bombs and the guys like
we don't have the Diplomatic immune and
he goes listen man I'm on a [__]
quote a speech the kingdom and the
kingdom that's a [__] badass movie I
was gonna say Ghostbusters he goes I'm
going to tell you a little space on
mccarthur man whatever he's [__]
slick this white dude slick
because it was a little speech and at
the end of this beach he goes I'd rather
walk out of there what does he saying
like he says I haven't seen it because I
either walk out of my feet or on my
knees I choose my feet
and he goes one of the first and they
tell you the Naval Academy is you have
to write your obituary oh my God he just
reads it to the guy but suddenly like do
you have an idea who you're [__] with
I don't know what the point of the story
was don't get me wrong everybody when
you just say you have to write your own
obituary yes who knows that's that he
goes to you you know he was just telling
the guy if you don't do this
you're gonna [__] die like you don't
understand like I'm just reading you
you're right act you know so I don't
even know how we got to this point Lee
what's going on with you Doug you good
yeah I don't know why I needed that just
sit there with that Suge Knight shirt
thinking to yourself what am I gonna do
with my [__] life thank Joey thank
God Joey's got pastelitos Becky got
pastelitos to go for later to balance
out your diabetic [__] sugar buzz you
know what I'm saying
they've been like Ninja ninjas throwing
stars around this place now we do it
that's what we are with Chinese [__]
ninja what do you throwing one at you
you haven't even felt the love yet this
[__]
oh there's one right here
[Laughter]
bring that over here listen man
tell the people everything there is
about this special your [__] family
what is this shadow box
comedy oh no that's just for me what's
the matter with you what's the matter
with you go ahead drop it on me drop
everything there is to them oh my
special well it's called you did this to
me okay who did it to you it's just it's
okay dude it's open you know I complain
about everything I complain about my
family and immigrants and my in-laws so
it's like everybody you did this to me
um I shot it seven months pregnant
crowdfunded so part of the crowdfunding
for 25 000 I think I told you right you
could cut the cord if you donated that
much money or if you contributed to my
crowdfund
um by the way no one no one bit that one
the 25 000 but for 20 000 you could help
us name our kid and somebody did give us
that
yeah they helped us name our daughter
yeah for you yeah you hit the jackpot
you did some creative things on it her
name's Tyrone really
so we raised the money and uh we shot it
um ourselves and I got distribution and
it's coming out finally a year later I
shot it Mother's Day of last year so
we're gonna have to go to a website so
it'll be on Amazon I don't know how
people find streaming stuff but it's on
Amazon it's on it's going to be Hulu and
um Netflix in June or July fingers
crossed please please
um Google Play Google play iTunes Dish
Network video and demand
all the places where you you know what
Vimeo is doing vimeo's releasing
specials I I don't know how it works I
found something called Voodoo like I
don't even know what Voodoo is but it's
gonna be on VUDU like I told you yeah
Deadpool's already out on that yeah yeah
it's gonna be on Voodoo wherever you go
find your streaming to spell your name
and say the name of the special no
honestly so people can search it that's
how they're gonna find it or Twitter
follow me on Twitter I'm sure
sultanovic so close are you [__] nuts
or what
At Kira comedy they can follow me on the
Twitter and I'll have info for people
here I gotta tell you man I've been
seeing you at the store since 98.
a young girl going up there with Adam
I wasn't wearing anywhere back then
either I wasn't looking man
looking at you and saying what the [__]
do they do up there is
underwear except for me barnhart's got a
good looking [__] women
you do too I always wear underwear oh
all right all right all right I guess
I'll try it
we'll see
if I made Jiu Jitsu I got on the way on
late night I got no underwear yeah I'm
saying I took a shower with these things
it's fresh that's it who gives a [__]
about underwear right or wrong I agree
with you the devil were underwear I mean
sure I do yes yes
beautiful times
you're [__] nuts
like that's the main people who complain
that people should wear underwear like
if you if you don't wear underwear
there's always a woman in the room that
says what if we get into an accident you
always have to have a clean underwear on
I never understood what difference that
made when they're trying to take your
shoulder out of your back No One's Gonna
care about your clean underwear so
I don't understand that I you know I
thought more guys went Commando than
women but you've mentioned it eight
times you didn't have it I I'm just
paying all over the stage like a cat you
talk about what you know right that's
what they think like a cat let me give
myself a shot don't forget I'm in
Indianapolis this weekend and I'm in
Sacramento 5 13 or 512 whatever we got
time to adjust it the most important
thing is tomorrow night at [__]
Indianapolis crackers we ain't [__]
around the stars are already there
voodoo's there it's crazy just make sure
you get tickets online for crackers
tomorrow night
always number one I love them with all
my [__] hunt for the shroom Tech
sport the hemp Force protein the best
chocolate [__] flavored protein on
the market I love it you know that's
what I meant I live for that [__] two
three four ice cubes two scoops a banana
but you're [__] brand new in between
meals whatever the [__] you know as far
as I'm concerned this is what I want you
to do I can sit here for two hours and
blow smoke up your ass and tell you what
the [__] I don't know go to honda.com
right now and look at the great
selection of supplements that they do
have and then take it from there I'm
sure you get something what I'm gonna do
is give you 10 off for your first order
delivered to your door so do me a favor
when you check out your [__] great
products go to the box and press in
church bam
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 off your first
order and if you want to do the stay on
it program they'll deliver it to your
house every month on the fourth first or
whatever the [__] you run out of it
depending on your body type and you know
how many pills you're eating or whatever
the [__] you're doing always remember
number
Alpha Brain money back guaranteed no
question when somebody does that I know
they ain't [__] now let's talk about
[__] you got smart cars smartphones
Smart Homes Technology has taken over
everything smart but losing your stuff
still makes Smart people feel [__]
stupid tracker makes losing things a
thing of the past
track is a coin size device that locates
misplaced coins wallets bags computers
anything in seconds just pay attracted
to your smartphone attach it to anything
okay I mean a bicycle whatever find its
precious location with the top of a
button it's not [__] easy lose your
phone press the button on tracker and
your phone rings even if it's an
assignment who does that for you with
over 1.5 million devices tracker has the
largest crowd GPS Network in the world
so your lost item shows up on a map even
if it's miles away never ever lose
anything again with tracker listeners of
the show get a special discount bam
thirty percent off your entire order go
to the
t-h-e-tracker.com and that's the promo
code church again the hardest thing
you'll ever have to find is their
website so do me a favor go to the
tracker
t-h-e-v-tracking.com right now and at
the promo code church for 30 off your
entire goddamn order again that's B th
for the stupid [__] the tractor.com
promo code Church
c-h-u-r-c-h I want to thank on it I want
to thank
tracker I want to thank me undies I want
to thank all our sponsors I want to
thank
my beautiful Kira sultanovic I want to
wish you a lot of luck on this special
that's coming on the second of mayo
thank you in Russian for people that
were wondering pernil is the name of the
pork yeah true [__] tremendous that's
what we had today we had
her human version of that at the Cuban
version of it oh my God Puerto Ricans
have it too they rub sand on it that
should make it taste like underneath you
know what I'm saying oh my God
it's amazing it's very little it brings
tears to my eyes when I think about it
as uh not too many people you have an
open invite if you need some you're
always family to the show you know I
love you
uh you need for me to plug into your
dates let me know you have any dates
coming up you want to plug
um I mean I'm I'm in Miami May 14th
we're at
I don't know
have it in front of me we'll get back to
me I'll get back to you for my girl
Felicia looking good looking Felicia's
sitting there like an innocent girl she
don't know nothing just waiting for like
a [__] dirty biker guy to come up
here and say you want some candy little
girl
police you'll get on that son's Anarchy
motorcycle you'll never see her again I
can see that that'd look good that's a
Felician knee she needs a white biker
like Jax Teller like I could see her
playing Gemma [__] no she ain't [__]
jamming Jim is a filthy animal this
Felicia Michaels you know I'm saying a
Muffler's clean do you see how nicely
put together Jenna's been on a
motorcycle you know what a motorcycle
seat does to your [__] after 15 [__]
years it makes it numb you can hit it
with a blow torch you understand me one
of those leather motorcycle seats you
sit on that thing on a July day that's
off Corinthian leather it melts the
clitoris it [__] up you gotta wanna go
on Wikipedia tell you all about it I
love you [__] huh is that why
you are so mad no oh wait we ever seen
bite the chicks they walk [__] up
their face is all [__] up between the
wind hitting their face and the way the
seat it's not ugly monkey that's on
their vagina they have calluses the
motorcycle engine is right under your
vagina which is the shake is what
creates the whole sperm Shake if you do
this constantly you lose the footing in
your [__] you got nothing they can hit
it with a blow torch a hammer a stick of
dynamite you're doing your nails it just
it just makes sense all those biker
[__] then numb
you look at me like I don't know what
I'm talking about I know exactly what
I'm talking about I know all about this
[__] I know some biker [__] back in
the day
they have a kid those [__] had kids
and their heads look like they got bit
by the mosquito already the Kiwi
whatever the [__] it is is it from the
zika I don't [__] know is that from
the storm chicks did the sperm Shake
cause the thing on the head no dog but
any even all those mosquitoes they got
on the bike you know get them stuck in
your teeth oh and they got the
encephalitis
we're gonna talk about this [__] I love
you [__] have a great weekend
stay safe see you in Indianapolis stay
black one more time my girl curious
autonovich May 2nd and Lee syatt and the
Beautiful Felicia Michaels stay black
Italy
or War Pigs for these [__]
you're tremendous so you are
foreign
thank you
everything
happens
foreign